bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france est-ce que selon vous c'est une
nouvelle crise migratoire qui pointe en
europe comment avez vous accueilli les
propos d' emmanuel macron lundi la
france n'acceptera pas des flux
migratoires irréguliers important venons
en afghanistan oui enfin il faut prendre
l'ensemble du discours de onze minutes
du président de la république et pas en
tirer des petites phrases comme cela
semble arranger certains et puis il faut
le mettre ce discours en parallèle avec
celui dans l attaque elle
qui a dit exactement la même chose
soyons clair lorsqu'il ya une crise
migratoire quelque part ce sont d'abord
les pays limitrophes qui accueille les
flux les plus importants donc le
pakistan l'iran la turquie sont en
premier
en première ligne le betis temps et
cetera
deuxième élément il faut faire notre
part du travail il faut le faire si
possible de manière coordonnée au sein
de l'union européenne
et pour ça je pense qu'il faut aussi
harmoniser les procédures en vigueur
pour l'excès au droit d'asile en fin de
troisième élément il y assure le
territoire européen aujourd'hui un
certain nombre de personnes qui sont
déboutés afghane qui sont déboutés de
leur demande d'asile et qui sont sans
droits celle là il faut absolument
laure donner une protection temporaire
mais je ne crois absolument pas à
un tsunami migratoire
en provenance d'afghanistan cela n'a
pour l'instant aucun sens et puis je
vous rappelle que ce qui arrive en
france en allemagne c'est eva
sont ceux qui ont le plus d'argent
pour venir d'afghanistan jusqu'à en
france ou en allemagne
ses coûts de 15 à 20 mille euros qui
vont enrichir les réseaux donc hélas je
dirai où
[Musique]
la plupart des afghans sont pris dans le
piège de la pauvreté et donc ne
bougeront pas de là où ils sont donc il
ya beaucoup de postures autour de cette
question
il ya des élections législatives en
allemagne ça ne va pas échapper à la fin
du mois de septembre
la question migratoire revient à
l'agenda et puis il ya des élections
présidentielles en france
l'année prochaine alors
alors je vous interromps simplement pour
revenir sur ce fait 216 personnes dont
184 afghans sont attendus apparaît dans
les prochaines heures quel accueil va
être réservé à ces réfugiés afghans
alors arrivé en france et bien l'accueil
qui a été réservé au 625 autres qui sont
arrivés déjà au mois de juillet ils sont
pris en charge par des organisations
spécialisées
dans l'accueil des demandeurs d'asile et
des réfugiés
et puis ensuite ils font une demande t
il à l'office français de protection des
réfugiés et des apatrides et la cour
nationale du droit d'asile si jamais le
a refusé leur statut en première
instance et puis ensuite
eh bien le travail d'intégration
commencera et il faut apprendre la
langue pour pouvoir espérer un avenir
dans ce pays et ils se retrouveront un
comme les huit mille deux cent cinquante
autres qui ont obtenu le les îles en
2020 en france voilà donc ni son ami
vibratoire
ni
accueil
inconsidérés
je crois que la france doit faire sa
part du travail et toutes les polémiques
autour de la déclaration du président de
la république sont pour moi nulle et non
avenue moi mes intérêts
ce qui m'intéresse c'est véritablement
le devoir dans un mois ou deux où nous
en serons très concrètement merci
beaucoup d'arabes et andré gerin sur
notre antenne pierre henry président de
france fera ternie t